a former Microsoft executive Jamin
Shibley he's gonna start the first
commercial pot company basically the
Starbucks of weed I think this is a
great idea it's starting to get
legalized across the country of course
it's still against federal law so this
is going to cause all kinds of problems
legally and you know can you get
investors and all that stuff do you guys
see this basically as you two pot
smoking maniacs that I know you are is
this this is just all good like somebody
had to jump into this space and this
will will help the legalization process
and hoping yeah he's giggling like a
STONER or at you until pot is legalized
on a federal level this guy it's gonna
be hilarious to watch this guy because I
know people who are licensed to grow
weed yeah and they have the card and
they're raided by the feds and the feds
are just like and the guy shows the card
and the feds are like all right I'm not
going to take you into custody but I
have my quota on how much pot I need to
seize a quarter and I know I can come to
you whenever and they take it and they
steal hundreds of thousands of dollars
of product and so he does not have any
recourse but to just start over and that
is exactly what happened to this guy
okay so I this is happening all over the
place actually where I live in West
Hollywood one of the places was rated a
legal place in California and then
you're right they take a certain amount
of the weed about what do they do with
the weed that's what I want to know they
just because if they're burning it then
I want to find out where they're I hope
they're just smoking the hell right
that's what I'm saying like but what was
really what do they do with the weed
when they confiscate drugs what do they
do with the drugs well just sell them
back to Mexico and then they sell them
back cause they incinerate it they
incinerate it they put it in a big thing
and they incinerate it and then they
reclaim the fumes and they don't let
anyone smoke it yeah now Fred I know
that I've birds flying over the top just
sending it out getting very fast yeah
Fred I know I can't say this too loudly
here but you are a Republican and which
means that I'm guessing you're really
four states right so I assume you see
this as a states rights issue where in
California the feds should have nothing
to do with this right well I do and I'm
all for marijuana legalization I think
it should be treated like alcohol it
should be controlled tax
there should be age requirements and we
should be reaping the profits as a you
know state federal local government is
opposed to these medical marijuana shops
that are charging the same price that
the street charges and I think one of
the great things Obama did from the
get-go was when he his Attorney General
said they would not be enforcing federal
marijuana laws in states like California
and 15 other states and what are they
actually I don't really know spiral yeah
they're hundreds and hundreds in LA City
they're trying to limit the number of
medical marijuana distribution stores
down a hundred and thirty just voted on
that last month so I'm encouraged and I
think the fact that this guy is trying
to treat it like a business raised money
he's got the former president Mexico and
a partner which is interesting Vicente
Fox but they want to bring the right guy
when from behind another country
basically to a weed sales well he's
getting up action and they take that
money and they put some money into these
other states like Colorado and
Washington that just legalized marijuana
it's just like gay marriage it's going
to take a number of states and then the
federal government will change the drug
laws and yeah that's the whole strategy
all if you guys want some numbers on pot
and how profitable is a United Nations
report in 2005 said the world wide pot
rate was a hundred and forty two billion
that was about eight years ago I'm
guessing it's a little bit more now um
honestly why let's just get let's go to
the philosophic okay this why don't they
want citizens smoking weed what's the
you know you mean like all beyond the
joking stuff like what why no one's
there's always there's always relative
icon weed people equated alcohol to vice
let's regulate it and have laws against
using it while doing things that can
endanger people such as driving and
everyone has said listen though you can
drive stoner yeah but you it's hard for
a police officer to verify how close to
the time of being arrested and driving
you were smoking pot because of how long
it stays in the system another in there
introducing better ways to judge that
but it's just not quite there yet and so
that's an issue yeah other than that
it's just been illegal see that's what I
think it is it's just so
systemic that no politician wants to be
the guy that's just purely associated
with pot it just makes him seem like the
pot Harry Johnson got yeah I look I look
the guy couldn't get in a debate and you
know he got too he also was the
libertarian nominee as governor two-term
governor of New Mexico he crusaded for
marijuana legalization from day one so
there it is a movement there's some very
wealthy people like George Soros and
Jonathan Lewis that are out crusading
for marijuana legalization and I think
the fear is it's a gateway drug and to
me who started experimenting with
marijuana in college it's much safer
than alcohol and it needs to be
legalized it needs to be regulated and
we can gain a huge amount of tax revenue
from it I but also as I get it it's a
gateway drug isn't that just insane I
mean if pot was disappeared altogether
there was no more pot around tomorrow
would suddenly everyone be smoking crack
I don't think that's you got a smoke
something it's I'm happy that robots
around so I don't have to smoke crack
exactly if you want to get off on
something let it be pot instead of crack
being sober is horrible her it is that
bad that I would smoke crack
just if there wasn't pot yeah eyes
advice what I want I don't want to be in
this guy's business I want to have the
like Steak and Shake next door to his
pot businesses so everyone goes in oh I
put together he's gonna need a name
oh well ever his chain little research
and so I found some traditional chain
restaurants and I did some plays on them
so instead of Applebee's there will be
Apple bongs maybe is a good idea
instead of Outback Steakhouse Outback
Bakehouse oh I like that instead of five
guys five guys who are really hungry for
pizza right now not burgers should they
be hungry for burger even maybe burgers
and then um instead of TGI Fridays TGI
wait what day is it guys get an applause
break yeah yeah it's just these TVs
these TVs alright final point on this do
you think that really I've mentioned
this before on the show but like my
thing with weed is that the government
just doesn't want us thinking they can't
have a populace that is gonna be
thinking about things and if you smoke a
little weed you might sir
thinking that this whole thing is just a
bunch of BS and and having some thoughts
that are a little outside the box the
government's not in that business is
that the real problem here I just think
that it's a lot of stodgy people who
have a misconception and as more and
more people there was a this guy running
for I mean I was nominated by Reagan for
the United States Supreme Court well
turned out in 1987 he is admitted
Ginsburg using marijuana well that was
unheard of and of course he had a
dropout well now that is not a
disqualification you've got the last
three presidents at least who have
experimented with marijuana and stronger
drugs and so there it's reflective of
society it's changing its changing
quickly and I applaud all those leaders
and and funders who are making these
will you ever vote for someone that said
no I've never smoked I honestly would I
mean probably would I wouldn't you don't
put pot as a I don't think it's like a
qualified you shouldn't be in the cop
it's like would you vote for someone who
doesn't drink and maybe I doesn't matter
I mean I don't trust them as much yeah I
mean you should have a glass of wine at
night it's good for your heart
absolutely the health reason